[Music]
welcome back
the white house doubling down on their
defense of the cdc after emails show the
agency took
word for word recommendation from one of
america's largest teachers unions
our next guest argues this could be a
winning issue for the gop in 2022
it's what they're about here to explain
wall street journal columnist and fox
news contributor jason reilly
jason if the republican stands for
anything is for putting the kids
first and it's for school choice
both these things line up to the actions
of democrats how
well we we know brian that that unions
exist
for the benefit of their members whether
we're talking about auto workers or
hotel workers or prison guards
the difference with the teachers unions
is that for years they pretend
that their interests line up perfectly
with those of our children
and the pandemic really exposed how what
a lie
that is you know the teachers unions
were looking out for their own interest
our kids suffer
academically from these lockdowns
mentally physically
and so forth and the teachers unions
could care less they're simply using it
as leverage uh to to to get more pay
more benefits and so forth
and i think this is something that the
republican party should not let the
public forget
they should remind them of this
constantly until the midterm elections
take this message into the community and
explain to them
why the teachers unions are looking out
for themselves and not for our children
and jason instead of opinion you have
the emails and you say don't just say
uh make these announcements and talk uh
and talk to your constituents
go out to places that didn't vote for
you go on black radio go on black
television
go into minority communities explain how
you are different
and explain what unions have left your
kids behind for example teachers unions
received
excuse me gave out 40 million dollars
two democratic causes to the biden
coffers specifically
and this is their payback where are kids
in this picture
republicans need to explain that
absolutely and as you said they need to
take this message directly to
these communities don't go through the
activists don't go through the civil
rights organizations like the naacp and
so forth
go directly to the people go to the
barber shops go to the community
senators
and advertise yes on black radio and
television and social media outlets
take this message directly to the people
and i think they will find a very
receptive audience here blacks and
hispanics in particular
favor school choice they long have
favorite school chosen polls
and what the republican party needs to
explain to them is
how school choice is the best response
to what
how the teachers unions treated their
children this past year
and jason that's what vouchers are about
i'm gonna give you this voucher
go to the school that's best for you
democrats say no we'll tell you where to
go
oh and by the way that school for the
last 14 months has been closed when you
go to school
your teacher's on remote that's what
they chose to do
over uh and allow your kid to lose more
ground
in in this marketplace
yes exactly they have not been following
the science following the facts
you know the irony here brian is that
the children themselves have held up
pretty well
against the the virus that the most
damage done to our kids brian
has been from the so-called experts and
their and their ridiculous mandates
they've done much more harm to the kids
than the actual virus and again
republicans need to to to take this
message directly to these communities
and again this isn't an identity
politics issue like the like the left
uses to go after minority voters this is
a principled stance
on education if you want to do something
about violent crime if you want to do
something about drug abuse and teen
pregnancy
and all the rest get kids a decent
education
and and that's what this is about and
the unions are not interested in that
they are interested in doing what is
best for their members right and that is
not what these
with these families need yeah this is
one of those things where everything
sometimes you
grab an issue and say it's good for me
and sometimes you're about that issue
and all and it happened and that's what
it is this is about schools
education putting kids first over unions
teachers are great the unions aren't and
that's what the message has to go
republicans have to stop trying to
maximize the vote they have and try to
get the votes they don't have
and that's what your column's about
jason riley thanks so much
thank you brian you got it great message